early on it seemed as if Muhammad's
ambition was simply to go from door to
door from person to person and say you
know leave alone what you believe in
believe in the one God the one who spoke
to me through the angel jibreel that's
how you say it in Arabic and Gabriel in
English and and then exhort people to do
certain things that in the 21st century
we understand as religion prayer fasting
congregations that sort of thing in the
first ten years in Mecca I would say
largely harmless there's that Muhammed
and in a very modern way I don't know if
you know dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde but you
could understand him as a dr. Jekyll
then he goes to Medina and then you have
the mr. Hyde side of Muhammad suddenly
there is a militia and now he's a
politician he is not only preaching
please come to the One God he's
demanding come to the One God and accept
me as the Prophet and if not I declare
war and he declares war and with a
relatively small militia at least
according to the Islamic perception this
is these are the Muslim documents with a
relatively small militia or a small
number of men he defeats a much larger
much more a well-established army and
that victory leads to another victory
and it leads to another victory needs to
another victory but it also leads to
complexities because the more he gains
power he has a say over more people and
that then leads to the necessity of
legislation in hindsight if you're in
the 21st century you are a political
scientists sociologists or psychologists
a historian any kind of social
scientists you look back in that time
and you read that narrative you'll be
impressed you'll see goodness this man
was great
he defeated larger armies he established
an empire he legislated he kept them
together and he left a narrative behind
that lasted many centuries well beyond
he was born wonderful of course I don't
argue with that
but what he also did was he froze his
innovation in place
he was the last prophet nobody else
could come and innovate on what he said
in fact he declares innovation the
biggest sin that I believe I can commit
thus the fate of the heretics of his
life and so if you if you take
Muhammad's as the Steve Jobs of you know
the seventh century I want you to
imagine I want you to think of a Steve
Jobs leaving a legacy behind where he
says you can never and you may never
change the minute he finds himself on
his deathbed never change the iPhone 4
or the iPad air I forget which
renditions these things were back then
or the Mac so that Tim Cook would never
have he would only have one thing which
would be to continue it and to say these
are timeless and that's pretty much what
Muhammad did the Quran is a timeless
document his example is rendered
timeless and I think that is a
disservice that Muhammad did to his own
innovation his great achievement was the
fact that he managed if that narrative
again that narrative is a contested
narrative but if that narrative is true
his greatest innovation was to unite the
Arabs make them France M by themselves
unites into a super tribe and conquer
but the biggest mistake he then made
would be to freeze things in place and
that is the curse of Islamists this the
fact that innovation is a sin innovation
is a bad thinking they closed the gates
reason that is the curse of that's the
firewall to Islamic thinking and we can
see the result in everyday life again I
repeat it's a perception of the people
who put these beliefs into practice what
really happened is still a matter of
study